Hãyhanh miền Thám Hội Nó và nghĩ khu chăm 20 xấu, đôi kẹn sất giò thông đường bộ số 1,
phòng kẹn sất giò thông công an tính ninh vình đã tính thành sự phạt tối năng thinh ninh vi phạm nhiều lối khi tham sản xà thông.
Chứ đó, nên lịch sấu thám Hội Nó và nghĩ khu chăm 20 xấu,
một tài sếu tô đã gửi tới ác, vì nhi chà phức đoạn clip thì lại kẹn một năng thinh ninh điều khiển xem một tô chảy trên đường tình bốn tám hai bê,
tục xá đường thái tính ninh viện không lội mũ bảo hiểm, môi vách sản chứng vũ.
Quà sát mình, xa định nhân vật chính trong clip là phạm đất tình,
sinh năm 2018, tình ninh viện tình bình.
Tại các quan công an tế đã thử dận là người có hình vi vì phạm lật xa thông trong clip,
đôi kẹn sất giò thông số 1 đã lập bên bản vi phạm hành chính với các hình vi vì phạm.
Không lội mũ bảo hiểm trong người đi một tô, xe máy,
phạt tinh từ bốn trong nghìn đến xóo chăm ninh đồng.
Điều khiến xe có phương xíu hộ bên trái người điều khiến như khu có tắc dụ,
Môi về một bên điều khiến xe, hình thức phạt tích thua phương tịt
tức quyền sự giống dưỡng phép là xe 2018 đến 2018.